the Senate expects to begin voting this
morning on amendments to its sweeping
tax reform bill a new congressional
report finds the Republican plan would
add one trillion dollars to the budget
deficit that news led to a standoff on
the Senate floor yesterday a key part of
the plan is cutting the corporate tax
rate from 35 percent to 20 percent
supporters say that would create
substantial economic and job growth but
not everybody buys that argument
Bloomberg Businessweek editor Megan
Murphy is with us with more on this
Megan I was only half kidding when I
said a lot of screaming going on the
trillion dollars wrong it's gonna and
many Republicans are saying ignore that
report ignore that report the math is
wrong but this was a bill that was
expected to be deficit-neutral supposed
to help the middle class who does this
really help the most there's no question
that this bill and its present form in
both the Senate and the house is a
massive transfer to the wealthy you can
look through any of its provisions in
terms of taking the corporate rate down
in terms of taking the individual root
rate down and passing right down we
could go on and on the problem they face
now is on two fronts Ron is on a
practical level as we've discussed their
own projections independent projections
show that it's not going to be able to
pay for itself in fact it's a trillion
dollars short over the next ten years
and only taking GDP up it projected 0.8
percent over the next ten years that's
not nearly enough to pay for the bill on
a theoretical level they face the
problem that so many economists just
don't believe that what we call
trickle-down economics that cutting the
top rate of tax for corporations for
individuals does enough to stimulate
economic growth and in fact doesn't
address the central conundrum in America
which is that wages just aren't rising
among middle class and working class
families fast enough so a major selling
point for supporters of the plan is the
reduction of that corporate tax rate
also CEOs from Pfizer and coca-cola say
that they would pump those returns those
gains to shareholders the economy is
doing well what can the pending economy
sustain the benefit from that well this
is the whole argument it's will
companies use that money that they're
getting back to pump into investment and
and keep expand job growth invest in
companies invest in manufacturing but
the problem is the evidence shows that
that actually doesn't happen what it
shows is that we see debt paid down you
share
five acts and we should mention more
money going to line top executive
pockets in the terms of more incentives
in fact what we've seen in the last
several decades not just in America but
in other countries is it's boosting the
lowest people on the rungs of society
that actually stimulate faster economic
growth this bill if you make under
$30,000 you're actually even paying more
in taxes people who earn the lease in
this country are gonna be paying more
the people who make the most are gonna
be paying a lot less so if it passes the
way they expected to the Republicans
today is this really the victory that
they are predicting it will be you know
Republicans feel like they need to get
this done they don't have a lot of
legislative a conference ministers show
as we know the problem is this risk
being a real albatross for them it is
deeply unpopular and it doesn't fit into
the dynamic that we face now in terms of
populism people are feeling left out of
this recovery they're feeling like their
wages aren't increasing fast enough and
that their opportunity is decreasing I'm
not sure this bill addresses those
central questions I think there's a
bigger astir Republicans look back on
this and think they really had a misstep
if indeed it does pass so you could win
the battle and lose the warriors that's
for sure and I think Obama knows exactly
how that happened with with his own
health care plan exactly right Meghan
Murphy good to see you thank you guys